daybreak in syria's idlib city
prayers mark the end of the islamic holy
month of ramadan and the completion of a
month of fasting from dawn to dusk
[Applause]
is a time for celebrations and respite
in a city that's been racked by civil
war since 2012.
but for some in the country's rebel-held
northwest
it's a solemn occasion
in this historic mosque in cairo people
arrive on mass for prayers and in larger
numbers than have been seen in years due
to the pandemic
of course eid prayer is a joy to us all
in the past couple of years we couldn't
enjoy it because of quarantine and a
nighttime curfew but this year it's
different
the day is celebrated with balloons and
traditional ice sweets called kak
muslims usually break the ramadan fast
with the first sighting of the crescent
moon for most this fell on monday in
india this was cited the next day
leaders from the us and canada sent
their best wishes to more than 2 billion
muslims across the world
muslim americans in my administration
have key roles in tackling the climate
crisis rebuilding our economy
safeguarding our health restoring our
alliances and so much more
after two hard years this ramadan and
this eid has brought everyone back
together russian muslims in kazan city
observed the holiday like so many across
the world with prayers new clothes food
and festivities
even though the war in ukraine has
caused a surge in food prices
i think that muslims around the whole
world are praying for peace for the
welfare of their families for a peaceful
life
this islamic holiday is a time to gather
and celebrate and now so many can for
the first time in years laura about
manly al jazeera